[Music]
before you see
john wick with extremely sad dad energy
revisit the sequels about a man with
care and hair killing anyone who gets
between him
and the manager i seek a meeting with
the one who sits above the team
john wick two and john wick three
parabellum
huh one of these titles is not like the
others
you remember john wick 1 when a gangster
killed john wick's dog so he very
understandably murdered everyone
now in john wick 2 he'll kill just as
many goons to retrieve his old mustang
that's worth like
50k tops and in john wick 3 he'll kill
so many people for such vague reasons
you'll start to wonder if vengeance
fueled murder sprees aren't just his
very specific fetish
i think you're addicted to it to the
vengeance
see mafia guy gets it that dead dog was
just the excuse he was waiting for
sorry experience keanu reeves just as
kick-ass and monotone
as he was 20 years ago what do you need
guns
as he plays the role of john wick well
into his 50s
and somehow gets better at fighting and
shooting along the way
rejoin this legendary assassin whose
name is still a laxative for criminals
it's not just a car it is john wick's
car
oh but three movies in
he's starting to maybe get a little too
powerful taking out every assassin in
new york
in a row while injured having him
straight up teleport once in a while
and giving him some kind of immunity to
being run over by cars
i mean come on i know keanu is great and
all but the same thing took out brad
pitt in his prime
[Applause]
don't mother watching the rest of me joe
black this is the only good part
[Applause]
go deeper into the secret world of
assassins and criminals
that lurks just under the surface to
discover that it's pretty boring
and barely makes sense featuring
their own silly cryptocurrencies this
coin it does not represent the monetary
value
it represents the commerce of
relationships you're handing your ticket
i will tear it for a man to grant a
market to another
is slowed off extreme amounts of table
matters
the ticket does not stand above the
table the high table wants your life
i had to follow the rules of the table
the eye table the high table
hive table under the table under the
table under the table
end of the table under the table serving
the table
everything is under the table and the
same kind of rules you make up playing
freeze tag at recess
you can't kill me but this whole
parallel society of killers and
criminals manages to stay underground
thanks to the continued silence of
everyone in new york
now
can you even say they're part of the
underworld seems like it's just the
world at this point
i mean even the homeless or a highly
trained network of super spies
no one can get between john wick and his
mission but that won't stop an army of
dumb schmucks from trying
as he'll fight through a rogue's gallery
of ethnic stereotypes
guys who literally bring a knife to a
gunfight and his fellow super assassins
who without exception
approached john wick from the front out
in the open for a little chitchat before
the fight
it's good to have you back you working
yeah you sure this is what you want to
do 14 million it's a lot of money
look i'm not a trained killer or
anything but just a thought don't
so enjoy this franchise that loves guns
so much you'll swear they're
compensating for something
i need something robust robust
anything for the end of the night
something big
bold that feels like it hates humanity
about as much as it loves animals
but as long as people are willing to pay
to watch keanu put his health and safety
on the line for our entertainment
they'll keep ending these things with
unapologetic sequel bait
even if he literally has to be wheeled
into his next fight
who's got more left in the tank keanu or
cruz my money's on tom
little guy freaks me out
starring the wicker man
never sneak up on a man who's been in a
chemical fire ruby rose
oh we're using our poor names then i am
dax slamhammer
porphius you see rats with wings
but i see the internet i used to love
him
siree national basketball assassination
dog woman ali cuisine also starring
headshots
like the regretful headshot
the almost forgot headshot the spinning
headshot
behind the back headshots
the halle berry
the come on in the intimate standing
headshot
the k9r
the put him out of his misery a charge
the now you see me headshot the grab and
go headshot
the john wikipedia
the throat slash plus headshot combo
platter
the dazed and confused they ain't
anywhere near the headshot
the mercy kill headshot
the chin shot the wild west
the lit the lid
the blatant overkill
the exploder
the exploder chunky style
and who even needs a gun headshot
[Music]
john wick checker 2 and john wick 3
lorem ipsum
okay is every killer for hire in new
york on the same group text
unsubscribe happy anniversary to the
goodmans
lizard beats monkey robot beats lizard
monkey beats robot we've been trying to
reach you
about your car's extended warranty
the pretzels are hurting my eyebrows
bittle juice three times